foreign
[Music]
networking demo Series in this video we
will be discussing private service
connect for gke multi-tenant clusters my
name is harika and I'm a network
specialist customer engineer and I'm
super excited to cover this topic with
you ready to drive in let's get started
oftentimes customers will use the same
clusters for different end users but
separated by different namespaces this
is because Google kubernetes engine can
offer multi-tenancy capabilities however
if one of the customers in one namespace
had to expose the service to their
on-prem environment or to a different
cloud provider there is no way we can
learn the routes on a specific name
stream instead the entire cluster will
learn the on-prem ranges which is not an
intended behavior for this multi-tenancy
scenario
now how do they decouple these IP
addresses how do we make sure that the
intended service is only being exposed
to the servers from on-prem or other
Cloud providers in a secure way
let's explore a solution using the
private service connect
private service connect allows private
consumption of services across VPC
Network that belong to different groups
themes projects or organizations
you can publish and consume services
using IP addresses that you define and
that are internal to your VPC Network we
introduced private service connect
endpoints based on a forwarding Rule and
with this endpoint consumers connect to
an internal IP address that they Define
private service connect for phones
Network address translation to Route the
request to the service producer in this
demo we will take a common gke
multi-tenant cluster scenario walk
through the sample requirements and a
solution team since this is an advanced
networking series the prerequisite for
this demo is going to be basic
understanding of PSE multi-tenant
cluster and internal TCP proxy load
balances along with the hybrid Network
endpoint rules get the common customer
scenario the customer has a multi-tenant
cluster separating each tenant and their
kubernetes resources into their own
namespaces
applications hosted on gke cluster users
from on-prem or from another cloud
provider wants to connect to the hosted
applications and vice versa
there is a ha VPN tunnel already
established between the two cloud and
on-prem or between Google cloud and
other Cloud providers remember this
havpn channel can always be replaced
with a cloud interconnect or a
cross-cloud interpreter
let's dig into the customer requirements
private and secure connection between
Google cloud and on-prem or other cloud
provider reduce management overhead
meaning solution should accommodate
overlapping subnets in case of expansion
reduced resource fragmentation which can
be achieved by multi-tenant clusters by
weapon and high availability of
applications
managed offering with less operational
overhead let's look at the network flow
where on-prem users try to connect to
the applications hosted on multi-10 and
gke cluster the on-prem or other cloud
provider is connected via ha VPN in a
consumer VPC and it can be in a
different project if you're using a
shared VPC since this VPC is exclusively
to terminate the VPN tunnels this can be
either in your organization where the
multi-tenant Clusters are configured or
in your end customers organization
note that this consumer VPC should
always be different from the VPC in
which this gke cluster resides
service or application should be exposed
via a load balancer with the forwarding
rules
to export the service a service producer
creates a service attachment that refers
to the service load balancers forwarding
room
when you publish a service you create a
subnet and choose an IP address range
if the private service connect subnet is
too small consumers might not be able to
connect to the service if needed you can
always make sure that you are adding
subnet and expanding the subnet ranges
when you publish a service you create a
subnet and choose an IP address range if
the private service connect subnet is
too small consumers might not be able to
connect to the service if needed you can
add more subnets or expand the submit
range enable a subnet in consumer VPC
for the fpsc endpoint this endpoint will
do a source net per the request coming
in from the on-prem and forward them to
the service attachment
to access a service a service consumer
creates an endpoint that refers to the
service attachment
each load balancer can be referenced
only by a single service attachment you
cannot configure multiple service
attachments that use the same load
balancer
when you create a service you can choose
to make it available for the consumer
project where the endpoint has been
configured this will ensure the
restricted connectivity to the service
attachment
note VPN must be terminated in the same
region as the PSE consumer endpoint
unless a global access has been enabled
for the endpoint
VPN has bandwidth limits that may
require additional tunnels to scale
let's look at the network flow where
multi-tenant cluster sponsor Services
try to connect to the application hosted
on-prem or other Cloud providers
here note that the producer VPC from the
previous flow became the consumer VPC
and vice versa
we are using internal TCP proxy load
balancer in the producer VPC with hybrid
Network endpoint groups pointing the IP
addresses on-prem remember the on-prem
is connected to the producer VPC via
Cloud VPN
subnet for service attachments and PSE
endpoint should follow the same rules as
we discussed earlier
gke cluster applications are fought
exposed will now become the consumers
for the endpoint created here is the
infrastructure that we are going to use
for this demo before you start
implementing the solution make sure you
enable the compute engine API service
directory API Cloud DNS API in your
project for this demo I am using
10.1.0.0 24 on both consumer oils and
services
to make sure that we can use overlapping
subnets for this scenario
due to time constraints I created vpcs
with the name vpcb and demo project and
vpca in both premium and Enterprise
projects all these vpcs have subnets in
central region and I also created a
private cluster with the name
multi-tenant cluster demo in U.S Central
One region in the demo project
created an nginx test deployment in both
the namespaces tenant 1 and 10 and 2.
you also I'm going to use Enterprise as
my Transit project where Cloud VPN is
going to be Terminator for tenant 1 and
premium as my Transit project where
Cloud VPN is going to be terminated for
10 19. remember both 10 and 1 and 10 and
2 have on-prem resources and in this
demo we're going to show AWS VM host as
on-prem host for convenience
in the real world scenario we can choose
to create these transit vpcs in your
customer organization or within the same
organization where you have your
clusters
however we need to make sure that in any
case your PSE endpoints and service
attachment should be in different
projects as you can see I have a havpn
up and running between AWS and gcp for
both the tenants remember that this VPN
can be replaced with interconnect
connection for private connectivity
let's move to the implementation part
select the services and create Ingress
creating Ingress will take some time
here I am creating Ingress for both
Services through internet 1 and 10 and 2
namespaces while creating the Ingress
you have an option to choose external or
internal HTTP load balancers
since PSE can only work with internal
load balances that is internal TCP UDP
internal Regional TCP UDP and internal
https load balances and choosing
internal
note that internal HTTP load balances
require a proxy only subnet also for the
health checks to pass add firewall rules
on backend services to allow traffic
from this proxy only subnet created
once the Ingress is created navigate to
the private service connect and click on
the publish services
choose the type of load balancer select
the load balancer for both Channel 1 and
you may have to create or reserve a
subnet separately for these published
Services here I am reserving
10.0.1.0 24 for 10 and one service and
10.0.2.01 for 10 and 27.
optionally you will have a choice to add
customer DNS means here which I chose
not to add for now and then in the
connection preference you can either
choose accept connections for selected
projects or automatically accept all the
connections I am choosing accept
connections for selected project and
adding Enterprise harith k for tenant 1
and premium
2. as you see you have an option to
choose the connection limit and rejected
projects here I am leaving the
connection limit as 10 which is my
default value once you publish the
services click on the service and you
will have the service attachment and ID
created please take a note of the
service attachment as we are going to
use this while creating an endpoint then
move to Enterprise project where you
have 10 and 1 Cloud VPN connection
terminated navigate to the private
service connect page and click on
connect endpoint here choose the target
connection and add the service
attachment that they copied in the
previous step
choose a VPC Network and subnet within
the region where you created your
cluster in my case it is U.S Central one
once you choose the subnet you will have
an option to reserve an IP address
you can choose to have a static IP
address where you can choose manually or
add something automatically
I chose an address
10.3.0.10 for this while this is getting
created we'll move to premium hurricane
project where 102 Cloud VPN connections
are being terminated I am repeating the
same process here and creating an
endpoint for the service attachment
created for genentune note that I am
using
10.0.3.10 again for the end point here
note that when you create a private
service connect endpoint it is
automatically registered with a service
directory using a namespace that you
choose or the default namespace Google
PSE default
once the end points are successfully
created the status of the end points
would be accepted if this does not turn
accepted we need to make sure that the
service attachment is correct and you
added the correct project ID in the
hello list now let's move to testing the
setup for tenant one I created an
instance on AWS environment within the
subnet
10.1.0.0 24 in Qs East one region here
is the ec2 instance I created and I'm
going to use this for my testing you can
see that the IP address is
10.1.0.152 for the end point we reserved
a static IP address
10.3.0.10 so let's try to call
10.3.0.10 on Port 80. boom it's working
we will repeat the same test for the 10
and 2 for 10 and 2 I created an instance
on AWS environment within the subnet
10.1.0.0 24 but here in US West one
region
here is the ec2 instance I created you
can see that the IP address is a
10.1.0.194 for the end point we reserved
a static IP address
10.3.0.10 so let's try to occur
10.3.0.10 on Port 80 from this instance
it's working again
and this is the end of the demo part one
that is the connections from on-prem or
the other Cloud providers to manage
services on gke let's move to the next
part where we work on the connectivity
from managed services to on-prem for
this we will need to create load
balances on both the tenant projects
premium and Enterprise here we need to
choose only between my VMS single region
only and the load balancer type should
be proxy
this is because the traffic should take
the IP address of the load balancer as
Source address on backend services and
not manage services IP range so in
choosing U.S Central one as the region
again as cluster is within this region
and I also reserved a proxy only submit
here as
10.4.0.024 for the front end I'm reusing
the existing subnet
10.3.0.0 24 which I created for the
endpoint you can also choose to use
separate subnets in The Next Step choose
hybrid neck and create a network
endpoint group
create the private IP address of the
server on AWS East one pertinent one we
should also create health checks for
this hybrid Network and point groups in
this step I am leaving all the default
values here and shows what to be 80. for
the backend I am giving the maximum
connections to be hundred and I'm
leaving rest of the values as default
while this is creating on this project
let's move to the premium project and
repeat the steps I use the same setting
even for this tenant to show that we are
using overlapping segments
10.4.0.0 24 for the proxy only subnet
and
10.3.0.0.24 for the front end IP address
once the load balancer is created I am
creating the service attachments for
both the tenants and choosing internal
Regional TCP proxy load balancer here
and the rest as default values
created a subnet when asked for the
service attachment in the connection
preference here I am adding demo project
as a project ID and I'm repeating exact
same steps for my other tenant
in the demo project I'm creating
endpoints now for both the tenants this
is because managed Services became the
consumer in the scenario and choosing
10.10.0.10 for the 10 and 1 and
10.10.0.11 for the 10 and 2 in this case
to test this connectivity I am logging
into one of the test VMS on demo project
since we are allowing the project for
the connection
curl to
10.10.0.10 is showing that the Apache 2
is being served from the tenant one
while curl to
10.10.0.11 is showing that it is being
served from the 10 entry during this
demo we can make sure that we are not
exporting any route to the VPC where you
have multi-tenant cluster configure and
you only have service attachment and end
points with this we come to an end for
the solution Gemma to get more
information on private service connect
best practices please read the
documentation and check out the link in
the description
[Music]